[Music]
[Laughter]
all right Conan O'Brien here welcome to
episode three of the reading of the Lost
Hans and frond script here with Dana
Carvey Kevin Nealon Robert Smigel myself
no reason to say hi really not at all
just I'm courteous and unfriendly yeah
and you're also chewing something which
I think fine let's cut okay he's like a
cow in the corner good it's just
[Music]
we find ourselves in this episode uh
we're in Beverly Hills and I think
there's an evil plot that's uh oh yes
that's it does it work here some girly
man abductions are going to take place
so let's set the scene
exterior Beverly Hills day muscle men
goons walking purposely down in Beverly
Hills Street they kick down a door rush
in emerge with Gavin MacLeod
in mid-eating sandwich the actor who
played the captain on The Love Boat a
goon spray paints one less girly man on
the wall oh Bob Saget was in this oh
sure too bad God Rest Your Soul Bob uh
our thoughts go out too what about Gavin
what about his soul oh right what about
Ebert yeah
it's got the only Soul around here what
the hell I knew Gavin McLeod that man
had no soul
Bob Saget on the set of his show Annette
is thrown over him in Musselman goons
drag him off insert TV screen a newscast
in progress a picture of John Ritter oh
my God is there anyone alive
what's your take on his soul would you
like God to rest it
a newscast in progress a picture of a
very much alive John Ritter over the
anchor woman's shoulder subtitled girly
nap once again a message was left this
time reading what a complete girly man
the total is now at 16 girly nappings as
insert another report a possible
breakthrough in the girly nap mystery
the term girly man has been traced to an
obscure bodybuilding program a clip of
pumping up with Hans and Franz has
played that was canceled not long ago
before the first girly nap occurred
interior Arnold's living room later Hans
and Franz and Arnold are lounging in
their Lederhosen
each drinking a blender full of protein
shake what do they mean obscure yeah
fellas this is not good why jealous
we're on TV we got big problems
Arnold's size and frustration exterior
Arnold's house Knights
boots and crafts and exterior Arnold
South Knight a salute of police cars
descend upon the house interior Arnold's
living room later several investigators
are questioning Hanson Franz as Arnold
watches have you ever used the term
girlyman yeah when was the last time you
used it oh about a minute ago as the
investigators take notes Arnold
interrupts excuse me Sergeant but this
is so ridiculous I've known these guys a
long time plus I'm a huge saw does not
count for some favoritism you're right
Mr Schwarzenegger we're sorry to take up
your time everyone gets up just then
discuss that easy it actually is just
then a few cops emerge from the basement
sir we've located a breakdown in the
security systems downstairs well Arnold
runs to the open wall where the box of
crackers is missing my crackles who
could have taken them only we knew about
them I mean but we didn't
I'm afraid we're gonna have to bring
your cousins in for more questioning
Arnold please let it wait until tomorrow
for God's sakes I'm bigger than Clark
Gable fair enough
also dead the investigator and cops
leave
we're innocent Arnold believe us now put
your hand on your bicep do you swear on
your cardiovascular system so help your
buttock muscles yeah yeah of course all
right so now what do we do we've got the
cops after you and I've got no crackers
I know it's really good in an exciting
yeah yeah I wonder what he thinks what
who thinks follow up Hans and France
runs through another secret door with
Arnold following them interior screening
room moments later Hans and Franz walk
behind the aisle towards Ebert's seat
Again movie critic Arnold Trails behind
what's the deal fellas pretty damn good
huh the seat is empty except for some
popcorn and candy yeah you bet they
noticed the empty seat and looked the
camera
interior layer same Roger Ebert is
struggling on a cross-country skiing
machine
yeah
fairing shorts in a tank top a muscle
man goon cracks away behind him as he
Huffs and puffs Rolf walks by spand or
discipline this one's a project oh the
one lieutenant
with these mass building
crackers or plan cannot fail augments
feeding immediately soon the girly man
will be ready to enter the Mr little
Austria contest where I will display
them to the world yes
good and what about the environment oh
it's smarting
looks right to camera
insert movie screens the same scene is
continuing on the screen Rolf and Mr X
Laughing interior screening room Hans
and Franz are watching it gently sitting
and eating Ebert's popcorn
unbelievable it was wrongful long what a
card he's got my crackers and how about
the other guy yeah with the voice yeah
he's terrible too it's a great movie
though yeah but the crackers they're not
ready to be eaten they're going to have
side effects terrible side effects
you've got to get back to little Austria
and stop them the entire town is in
great days no how much time into those
side effects they will take effect
turning right into camera in T minus 72
hour music dramatic sting as Arnold
speaks at digital clock Rita marked time
until side effects 72 hours appears on
the lower side of left corner and
immediately starts ticking down oh no
but what do we do you've got to get the
antidote to the girly man here it is
Arnold produces and hands them a can of
cheese whiz it comes in the form of
cheese
now go
all right well clearly uh we keep
inserting words we just want Arnold to
say like cheese whiz and crackers
this is one of my favorite things in the
movie this is one of my favorite things
I ever the Siskel and Ebert thing or it
was it was originally Cisco in Eber but
Ebert that was funny to me to just put
have Arnold and I mean have these guys
walk and watch a Critic in the middle of
the movie like several times but then it
got to this stage of the movie and all
of these bad comedies back then had like
there were two things that I really
wanted to do in this movie was like have
the bad guy be funny yep which just what
didn't exist like all these 80s movies
were funny in a lot of ways but they
would always have that serious bad guy
like Max von Cito that you'd like to
take into Marvel movies now where
they're all like at that little kind of
a oh everything they twist everything's
a wink Yeah Austin Powers Austin Powell
he's like he he cracked the code he came
up with a character as funny as uh as
the main guy but uh but the whole raw
thing for one thing like I love that
because it was like it was sort of a
final solution I mean it's from my dark
Jewish sensibility when I was like a
good morning I thought it was a little
yeah no it's the bad guy who wants to
take uh who wants to take what you guys
do way too far right yeah and then the
other thing in these movies was there
would be like these messages about
things like the environment yes in these
bad 80s comedies like they tried to have
a morality play going on at the same
time a lot of it got into the save the
world mentality yep so it's comedy I
love the idea that wall is this uh
Caddyshack or what do you which ones no
not Caddyshack but like Spies Like Us
kind of movies or Dragnet they were all
there were a lot of serious bad guys in
these movies and that would sort of stop
the film cold so then here I love the
idea of like Ralph he had his he had his
first plan about you know just
eliminating girly men but then just
tacked done gratuitously and I'm going
to hurt the environment yeah what's also
that it's just a button yeah he just
pushes a button that hurts the
environment
yeah yeah so we get to this point in the
movie and another device that's always
in these kinds of movies is like you
have to figure out a way for the hero to
find out what the bad guy's up to and
it's always some lame device overhearing
you know it's a button over here yeah
the over here button and here like they
can accidentally we'd set up this thing
where Ebert's watching the movie so they
walk in and instead of it just being the
third version of this joke they actually
get to watch what's happening what they
find out about the bad guy right by
watching the movie I think it's is it
meta is that yes
that's not a joke ever yes that's right
not the Facebook pattern company I also
love that when you read a script a
normal script oftentimes if someone's
introduced it says someone like a Kirk
Cameron or someone like but we're you
know I'm just throwing out random names
or some you know someone like a Rob Lowe
but but because we were starting with
the assumption that Arnold
Schwarzenegger is going to be more than
half the movie Once you once you've
swallowed that pill we go Hog Wild and
it's and and suddenly we're just
throwing people in the movie left and
right without a doubt hey we gotta do it
if Arnold will do it if Sonny Bono will
do it yeah Arnold's just Arnold can just
call people up and say you're doing it
and he was you know he could do it yeah
so I love that I love that just the we
were so sure that everything big sure we
swung for the fences hmm and ultimately
no one did it is that right yeah no one
did it didn't come to fruition well No
you're ruining the endings I think a lot
of people listening don't know what this
movie was ever made or not so let's keep
that as a possibility maybe it did come
out here maybe maybe they read the book
maybe it was a massive 1992 hit could
have been man there's a lot of hits from
192 have been forgotten so why why not
just yeah let's just tell people it was
made and it actually did pretty well and
this is a big Reunion yeah exactly the
real Arnold's on his way based on a true
story well let's not say that's never
been made yet what can say that yet yeah
Never Say Never yeah no pain no gain
all right should we get back to it
Arnold to CERN with his Hollywood career
to leave sends Hans and Franz back to
little Austria to infiltrate Ralph's
evil lair and save the girly men from
becoming out of control muscle-bound
monsters exterior Highway night Hans and
fronds ride their tandem bike down a
dark Highway almost there yeah soon
we'll be heroes but how do we get into
the Evil Lair to save the galiman well
I'm afraid there's only one way exterior
Urban landscape day Hans and Franz
approach interior little Austria
entrance same they have gone undercover
as girly men and wear exaggerated
disguises Hans excessively effeminate
Franz excessively nerdy clock reads 21
hours 6 minutes 28 seconds
enter your little Austria Town Square
same they Mill about trying to get
noticed my look at all the pretty
flowers
yeah I would look at them but I'm too
busy not exercising a few muscle men
goons see them and whispered each other
Hans addresses a woman oh you simply
must tell me where you got that top yeah
I can't believe my squinty lose her eyes
the goons approach them would you two
gentlemen like to come with us for
whatever fall Hans and Franz share a
wink as they are taken away interior
Ralph's Lair moments later Rolf is
examining Hanson France who continue
playing up their disguises clock 21
hours one minute 48 seconds so glad you
could join me I have special plans for
the both of you Hans and France
Hans and Franz surprise drop their
attitudes take them away hunting franzer
grabbed and hauled away we should have
known it would be impossible to hide our
considerable yeah yeah but I think you
did have them fooled for a minute I
think you are quite mistaken my friend
if you thought anyone was a curly man
interior Lair later Ebert is inside a
machine marked flabo suction
what's he gonna think when he read this
it is connected I'm aware listen
hahaha
just want to make sure I'm saying it
right is it plabo suction yes yes the
flag suction machine is connected
through a network of tubes to Hans and
Franz who are tied down to another
machine Rob stands triumphantly on a
perch above them the clock now reads
zero zero hours 11 minutes 16 seconds oh
my God how fortuitous of you to arrive
at this moment you see I was just about
to suck the flab from this humongous
critic
still reading even
but now that you're here the flab won't
go to waste our bodies will reject the
Eber flab yeah it's like oil and water
we'll see who can't accept Ebert flap
and then Ebert says could you stop
calling it Ebert flap please don't give
us a bad review enough commence flapper
suction
a muscle man goon hits a switch slowly
we see chunks of flab going through the
tubing towards Hans and France
what the hell's gonna happen I don't
know that was a cliffhanger guys we're
gonna drop off uh right there for this
episode I mean this is uh that's
incredible Hans and Franz are tied down
while chunks of fat are being taken out
of revered
Ralph was the idea for to play Ralph was
Dolph Lundgren yeah that's right yeah
yeah I look at the part where uh Dana
doesn't want me to think he really was
effeminate yeah or a girly man yeah
there's still bickering about they've
been caught and probably know they're
about to be killed but they're bickering
about we weren't convincing yeah that
was more convincing yeah yeah yeah we
were not that's the reason you must
possibly do this you didn't want anybody
to think you were convincing enough to
be a girlyman so laughable that anyone
could think we were properly pumped up
is there funny I always thought we were
feminine I knew it never worked there's
no disguising with these things
guys had we let's say it had gone ahead
and it had come time to send the script
to Ebert
just picture I know that it would have
been Robert and I yeah
on the phone or in person saying hey we
want to talk to you and then how would
we sell that that it's all about you're
you're flat yeah what would be in it for
him I got to experience this years later
doing Triumph yep yep and I would get
people to do stuff in advance and it was
always hilarious right
and I think Ebert I mean I think in this
case Hans and Franz were already hit
characters aren't if Arnold had really
done the movie I I honestly think a lot
of these people do you think Ebert would
have done it yes I do yeah interesting I
don't think Cisco would though Hebert
was the good one another too
you know what and then
you brought up Triumph and I think it's
it's worth remembering I remember uh
when Triumph got got really big and huge
people would contact the you know us and
say oh oh I want uh Triumph to get me
and I remembered it was Bon Jovi Bon
Jovi that was Richie sambora's
completely yeah Richie sempora wanted it
and so yeah and the guys were all
excited and they put Triumph's picture
on the backstage they're backstage it
was a big thing and then I remembered
you went there and all the jokes were so
mean right about Jon Bon Jovi and you
thought at the end is there some part of
him I remember there was like he was not
he was the only one he's very nice to me
more in later years but I could tell
that he was he was not as into it as
well he was really into getting his his
acting career going and you said yes I
understand in this in this movie you
play a vampire finally I'll roll that
requires you to suck yes and I saw those
Stacks jokes I saw the light go out of
his eyes a little bit and I thought oh
yeah yeah I think with Ebert on the
set getting the thing hooked up I I
think yeah
I know he wouldn't have walked he
couldn't have he's attached to a hose
that was the trick that's I see get your
cameos and tied up to an object yeah
yeah that was my trick but I could
triumphed no people like Joey Fatone
they're dying to get out there and be
shot on right
I mean it became a high honor like
having Rickles on you it became I
remember yeah but we did a Triumph on uh
late night where and Simon Cowell was
sitting right next to me and you tore
into Simon Cowell and I'm sitting right
next to him and you really go at go at
him and after it was over he looked at
me and he was covered in sweat and he
went that was rough yes that's so funny
because like I remember afterward him
telling me no this will be good for me
no no no but he while he was going
through it he said it was that's so
funny what would be your opening line to
Eber to try to get him to do this I
would say uh Roger how are you
congratulations Arnold Schwarzenegger
biggest star in the world because it's
1991 wants you to be in his next film
okay and he doesn't want Cisco and he
doesn't miss him yeah oh I see that was
Michael what would you say to him to
Ebert yeah um I would have said uh uh
this is uh read the script and see what
you think uh I would have tried to be
very complimentary that we love your
show and so you would let him discover
what the thing was alone I would have
said it's you know no I would have set
up the story I would have said you're
gonna be there's gonna be a whole bunch
of celebrities that uh this this evil
guy wants to convert into muscle men
okay I mentioned that I wouldn't have
said that they're all flabby can I say
one thing I would have done yeah I would
have gone back reread it and taken out
the line that Rolf has you see I'm just
about to suck the flap from this
humongous critic
I would have just deleted the line
humongous and then added it on the day
of the shooting Dolph improvises you
know Dolphins you know yeah once you get
Dolphins we're just gonna try one take
where he calls you humongous we won't
even use it I didn't see the flower
suction thing in here before did you add
that the flower suction dang that what
would you say seriously I would I'd be
cute I would compliment him yes you are
so averse to conflict you'd be nowhere
around I would tell him well I would
tell him you don't really have to do
this you don't need it sure yeah you
don't need it but we think it's uh a lot
of good fun ridiculous you would have
said it's ridiculous silly the
characters are silly the whole thing is
in good fun everyone is having fun in
this movie yes and and having fun with
their image so I think it would be
really funny uh Roger or R whatever uh e
EB
um yeah I just would have tried to
butter them up smooth them over about
this like and Triumph and what I did but
like you every Everybody you
impersonated well like for example
Arnold was dying to do the sketch on the
show and John McLaughlin and Reed Jesse
Bush president your friend yeah all
these people were thrilled because now
we're talking about things like a flab
out of them oh but you know it was still
pretty uh here's what I would say and
this is why I'm not a good negotiator I
would open up like this Roger you're not
gonna like this
how about this Roger you're not gonna
like this but first let's concede you
could lose some yeah yeah lose a few
pounds well
well a competition with Cisco was there
another reviewer that he would maybe
hate and we go we rejected him yeah we
rejected this up or he's hauling Cape
it's not you we're gonna get Pauline
kale and then he has to right then he
has to do because he wants to deny kale
the yeah
inside baseball how to manipulate people
to do your project yes Conan O'Brien
next week Al Roker yeah all right this
is the end of uh episode three join us
for episode four where we uh we we read
more of the Lost Hans and Franz movie to
a nation that just can't get enough
we'll see you then
[Music]